he is a fellow of the american
geophysical union and american
meteorological society and he's also
former Fulbright Scholar as well as a
Guggenheim Fellow notably Peter was
awarded the prestigious American
Meteorological Society star award for
outstanding contributions to the
advancement of understanding the physics
of the ocean and Peter's research and
teaching spin a very broad range of
topics Peter's very well known for among
many other things his laboratory
experiments for understanding fluid
dynamics on a rotating planet so we're
very happy to have you thank you Peter
pleasure to be here the I haven't been
to Yale for a long time but I I grew up
in Connecticut a little north of here
and most of my classmates went to Yale
which that's 21 of them in fact in my
high school and I was the black sheep
that I've been I didn't do that I didn't
want to be an investment banker but here
I am back home and it's really fun to
see this the great department that I'm
visiting and Klein geology and the
diversity of science here and really
high quality stuff you can all be proud
of what of your environment and what
you're doing so I'm sorry yo this slides
will be cut off in some ways I hope it
won't be too bad but I wanted to start
out showing this through the cloud
long-wave radiometry that Tom Agnew of
Environment Canada has produced for the
four Arctic ice and we're seeing through
clouds to see the flow out of the Arctic
down both sides of Greenland and this is
a sort of a running running theme
through what I'm interested in today and
particularly the way that fresh water
impacts that the oceans to the south
we're just north of the Labrador sea and
the northern Atlantic so these are my
collaborators cerveja cannon
at NASA Nick beard my grad student is
just finishing it at Seattle and Charlie
Erickson who designed and built the seat
gliders as I'll show you Helen along a
haagen Norway shall be au jus and fart
estate our chassis knee and Bill
Schmidt's an old friend of mine from
Woods Hole and so I Who am I let's see
what we got here now well we got some
it's like a haiku isn't it you have to
fill in the why are we interested in the
sub holer zone especially in the north
atlantic the it has to do with people
and echoes ecosystems natural resources
everything is on the move the natives of
the far north are lived there
successfully for maybe six thousand
years and yet their their world is
changing now and it's a concentrated
region for the global climate system
it's a headwaters of the oceanic
Meridian overturning circulation center
of variability de kadel multidecadal and
as one often hears the Arctic rim is
where the cryosphere changes may have
the greatest impact and it's a leading
edge of global warming so that's lots of
reasons to be working there and the this
is kind of a list of thing learning this
is not a technical talk on computer
model building and I don't know quite
how technical to be I know many of your
faces but not all and so I I've cuts
trying to do tread a fine line between a
really technical lecture and one that's
a little bit more general about the
climate of the far north but what the
subjects I'm interested in are a set of
examples really about the ocean
circulation dynamics of high latitude
particularly in the Atlantic and
particularly to do with fresh water and
and ice dynamics and the both the
overturning circulation of the Atlantic
and the lateral gyres which are mostly
driven by wind heat content and
circulation of n modes of variability
and possibly active feedbacks to the
atmosphere in atmospheric circulation so
starting with fresh water and ice
dynamics it's good to remember that
density stratification is is really one
of the absolutely most important
variables in the ocean for its impact on
ecosystems and and heat transport and
many other things density stratification
temperature and and the way it controls
circulation so this is the at least part
of the global ocean circulation is seen
by grace gravity satellites and eltima
tree from satellites and surface
drifters all put together in this case
by the aviso group in France the these
contours are cultures of sea surface
elevation relative to the geoid a mean
time averaged over the 1990s and you can
see that the subtropical and subfolder
gyres of the pacific here are a cyclonic
candy clockwise dryer and here a anti
cyclonic clockwise dryer if I said that
right and in the Atlantic similarly
beautifully did well 11 still has
questions of accuracy of course but if
we're homing in the community is homing
in more and more accurately on this on
this field which has to be the reference
field for satellite altimetry in the
Atlantic which will focus on that little
yellow bar is in crossing the Labrador
sea it's a repeat section from the
Canadian group in eastern Canada the
aloe section ar7 W and the blue Labrador
sea there is a psychotic gyre very small
but very important in its it's one of
the densest surface water sites in the
world ocean where the atmosphere can
talk to the deep ocean so to speak and I
signal surfaces constant density
surfaces that rise up and deep
convection to two and a half kilometers
often occurs there and and sometimes
doesn't and further south is the
familiar Gulf Stream system and it's oh
my golly have to be careful weather
clicking or pointing I don't see a
pointer here actually that's one of my
problems but the this the Gulf Stream
system this is again the time-averaged
geostrophic flow field for that system
and you can see that it's both a gyre
but it's also reaching up into the
northern realm carrying in its of course
part of the overturning circulation
bringing warm water to the far north
which is of great interest to us so if
we to a cross section on that yellow
line across the Labrador sea this is
what the salinity field looks like in
2002 in the spring and you can see a
little bit of confusion there but
largely that you have salty water in the
depth and fresh water starting at twelve
or fourteen hundred meters and then
above in the sort of cyan color and then
the deep blue color is buoyant low
salinity water floating over the top of
the Labrador sea and it's come off of
the boundary currents in west greenland
and it's an important part of the talk
because it's such a fine scale feature a
delicate feature and yet it has a lot of
integrated buoyancy in it and so it's
it's like a blanket lying over the top
of the sea insulating it from the
atmosphere the atmosphere has mixed down
trying to be gentle here and just point
mix down that far in the winter deep
convection the cold arctic air flowing
out from Canada sometimes as I said
reaching 2,500 meters depth creating new
water masses and creating a significant
part of the overturning circulation of
the entire Atlantic one of one of the
components of North Atlantic deep water
but it has to fight against the the net
buoyancy on the top and and so this is
where climate models and and other
models begin to disagree and it's where
you have to get out there and kind of
measure stuff and not just run models so
oh thank you oh that's so great I feel
better so this is what you have to do
sometimes in the Labrador sea
in order not to capsize keep the ice off
your ship at least for fishing boats
this is the nor a larger woods hole
oceanographic vessel but we've done a
lot of that work with the Canadians
making those sections and people like
John lazier of Canada have created
wonderful time series which are as years
go by they become more and more
important the endurance of
oceanographers who keep going out and
resampling again and again builds up so
after a decade or so you begin to really
speak to the entire climate community
and that's the value of these difficult
cruises and in difficult weather but we
do have modern technology and so some of
us particularly those of us who are
aging might want to stay home instead
and just send your robots out there so
this is a sea glider from Charlie
Erickson at University of Washington who
took a fanciful tale of Henry's Tamil
are one of our greatest of
oceanographers written many years ago
and built this autonomous undersea
vehicle which does hydrography measures
oxygen measures velocity measures
particle scattering fluorescence
biological quantities and it's self
propelled and talks to phones home three
times a day a thousand meters the the
new verte the new version glider see
glider too will go to 6000 meters and
that's about as deep as you need to go
it looks a little like a narwhal which
they live in the same region and i'll be
talking about these tomorrow over in
client geology a little bit more and but
the so you've got a robot you've got the
problem to solve and you but you need
people and collaborators so we've kind
of worked with a wonderful hike latitude
network of people and oceanographers and
sites to launched gliders from from nuuk
the capital of west greenland of capital
greenland to wreck evict to the Pharaohs
to bergen norway to stockholm to Oban
scotland and this network every one of
these little islands are big islands has
oceanographers and environmental
scientists on it we've had a wonderful
a wonderful time working with people in
all of these places too because they're
hydrographer 'he's they're great they're
great people to work with him when we
had a government we were funded by these
people and we hope we will again so that
we put the sea gliders in this was the
first major trial of sea trial of sea
gliders in back in 2003 and we've been
constantly for most of the last 10 years
working in the northern Atlantic with
these robots and this is a track of to
see gliders number four and number eight
over october through februari the winter
of that at that time and there there
were we launched them 100 kilometers
offshore in in between two very strong
storms in a small boat and they chugged
south where 2,000 kilometers or so and
then continued to serve a north and
south and across this is the line of
hydrography that i showed you a minute
ago the vectors are the depths average
velocity of the ocean and the glider
also measures the surface velocity and
vertical velocity so we have a lot of
interesting variables to come home with
but what i mostly want to show you is
just one one set of data that comes out
of this that program this is the the
region scene is ocean color and if i
zoom in on the central basin of the
subpolar gyre here and there's greenland
in the region that we're working in with
the gliders labrador sea no this is the
spring bloom of phytoplankton and not
coincidentally it's happening in just
the region we're working and just the
region that has that fresh water layer
on it excuse me how did that happen what
you see here as an overlay is the sea
surface temperature from satellite and
the blue region is a cold tongue coming
out from the coastal current the deep
and both the deep in the shallow coastal
current of west greenland streaming out
over the top of the labrador sea and
these are the tracks of to see gliders
in that plume at that time and so what
we
measured there is the is the detail of
the freshwater cap that I showed you on
the long section and the it's both a jet
of circulation which is the part of the
subpolar gyre the cyclonic subpolar gyre
the region deciding to separate from the
western boundary and flow over across
the Labrador and that actually happens
in two branches one further up near bath
and bay and so this is the same picture
again with a plant low some of the layer
floating on top and what what's having
the in-situ measurements from the
gliders and from these sections it
allows you to quantify the amount of
buoyancy in this region and then develop
an idea both of the structure of the of
the offshore circulation which is shown
here here we're trent we're repeatedly
sampling one of those Eddie's and you
see this is the center of the eddy and
this is the azimuthal velocity it's a
eddie reap that reaches down eight or
nine hundred meters and is more or less
symmetric anticyclone and this on me on
the right side is the half image of the
salinity field so you see the freshwater
blanket that I mentioned and we've seen
but also its carrying warm old tired old
Gulfstream water from the ER mming or
see down below but it's that extra
buoyancy at the top which is so
influential if we add up the buoyancy
and for one of these thousand kilometer
long tracks of the gliders the buoyancy
is very high where you have a lot of
fresh water in the davis strait we come
southward and it becomes essentially
zero where you're having deep convection
and this is in wintertime we've lost the
time scale I'm sorry to say but this is
deeply convecting here so there's no
buoyancy barrier but then we pick it up
again as we head south towards Labrador
and the salinity contribution to it is
dominant so what we get in the end is a
map gradually filled in of where where
this blanket exists and what and what
happens is that the offshore flow
carries that the freshwater out to the
southwest
leaves open just a small region where
deep convection can can occur with great
ease without the barrier so instead of
when the cold arctic canadian air
streams across the labrador sea you
would normally expect and indeed many
climate models expect that the whole
region will convict deeply but this
intervention of of Arctic water prevents
that and creates about a 100 kilometer
region where d convection occurs in the
mean so that's a first listen the
question what does that have to do with
climate models the point is they have to
resolve some of these effects because
these they have these events in a way
are greatly influential or maybe even
controlling over the water mass
transformation in the region creation of
Labrador sea water that cold freshwater
you saw in the section and that ends in
in in a real measure affects the
Atlantic Meridian overturning
circulation because this is a Labrador
sea water as a it's one of the three
major components of North Atlantic deep
water the the deep water mass of the
oceans so and so that's part of the
title of my talk what climate models
have to learn from learn about the
subpolar ocean and what you'll hear me
say later in the talk is that we need to
somehow learn to insert these fine scale
features like that advected thin layers
of buoyancy into climate models even
though their resolution can't be high
enough to resolve them completely and we
can do that by using neighboring high
resolution ocean models so that's where
we're headed further south where the
Gulf Stream sends warm subtropical
waters northward that's the opposite
part of the conveyor belt the warm water
going up to feed the oat feed the
sinking cooling waters of the North
there's also there is also great heat
loss to the atmosphere in winter so it's
not just in the Labrador sea this is a
global map of the mean upward heat flux
from ocean to atmosphere from British
NOC data Simon Josie Adele and
red regions are where warm ocean is
warming the atmosphere and being cooled
by the atmosphere and it's not
surprising where they are the Kurus hero
in the Gulf Stream but it's very
important to see how far northward this
region of ocean heating the atmosphere
extends right up to the barents sea the
barents sea is miraculously ice-free
even though it rends up almost to 78
north or 76 degrees north very high
latitude see but it's ice-free and
therefore because of this the
combination of ocean and atmosphere
storm track carrying warmth northward it
maintains that free surface and hence
its interaction with the atmosphere so
if we kind of zoom in a little bit on
the Atlantic and think about not only
the Labrador sea where we just have been
but this extremely strong track of ocean
warmth just rounding the corner here
east of Newfoundland here are three
hundred year time being pictures from
two couple climate models I won't name
them but if you look hard you can
probably see what they are but they're
this is the IPCC class the IPCC report
just came out last week up with a new
story about our climate system and its
changes a wonderful document I'd say but
the the models which are feeding that
report so heavily are have do have
coarse resolution in both ocean
atmosphere and so they they really are
struggling to resolve some of the
effects that we're talking about now the
warm Gulf Stream effect which I just we
just looked at is totally absent from
this model and more or less absent from
this model here this is the upward
buoyancy flux on me unmodded so it
should be compared with this these
pictures here and it's not right enough
and the reason is there's the ice models
and these are not quite right and so you
get a blanket of anomalously freshwater
low salinity water streaming out of the
Labrador sea and prevent making that
blanket again so the blanket is not
where it should be but it is where it
shouldn't be and the
a crucial excitation of the atmosphere
by the warm ocean is is missing in that
model in these two models and so that's
interesting and something to work on and
diagnose the really the geography of
where heat and freshwater are moving in
the system is what we need to keep
better track of but excuse me they were
the difference is that one was run by
norwegians and the other by the French
that's that's the difference you know
there are a large number of this is from
a paper by Hannah on Ilana Hagen to RL
de Vic and myself comparing three of
these IPCC models with with observations
and now so the question is the next
question is does this matter I mean is
it important if all you care about is
the atmosphere and weather in Europe or
whether in Canada or us is it important
that the models are struggling to get
these details right and one very closely
rated thing is that this this error I've
just showed you as a cold bias of
climate models and it's widely present
and it arises well I said it was because
of the ice of the ice effect but it's
another effect as well that the the
observed Gulf Stream turns left here and
becomes the North Atlantic Current heads
up to do its work in the far north but
the the the coarse resolution models
can't make that turn and so they're
Gulfstream's tend to go across towards
Europe and they that leaves a cold bias
in the sea surface an error where the
sea surface has not been warmed by the
Gulf Stream yet it should have been and
Adam sky fat at London has explored this
and he simply said well let's remove the
cold bias and see how the keep
everything else the same in these models
the same atmosphere and see what happens
and so he increased his ocean model too
well a quarter degree resolution which
gave it a good enough a better Gulf
Stream track it turned left here and
went up further north rather than
gliding
towards the UK and this is the change in
the in the surface temperature that
resulted so he could he was able to
remove the cold via simply by moving the
Gulf Stream North Atlantic current
system to where it should be and what
did that do well what happened was that
atmospheric blocking frequency went from
much too rare here this is the Atlantic
sector here between the Greenwich
Meridian and say 50 West so here is what
the models were doing four episodes of
blocking in wintertime and here was the
observations from er a 40 or something
like that and here is that the model
with a corrected cold bias where the
cold bias removed so it was vastly
improved at least at least halfway
improved by doing this and so that's
that's a serious question because we
know the ocean and the mean affects the
climate system of the earth the
climatological mean there's no doubt
about that both in the tropics and in
these high-latitude regions but what we
don't know is whether there's a lot of
feedback interactions so that changes
small subtle changes in the ocean
possibly can make great changes in the
atmosphere that's really an ongoing
constantly changing debate and very
model dependent but by changing you see
this cold bias was about between three
and four degrees maybe a little higher
than at the center and so you might say
well that's a lot of correction and we
don't have that in natural fluctuations
this is a correcting a model error it's
not changing it's not watching the ocean
change but however that's not quite true
because well see because the ocean
actually can present sea surface
temperature changes of that same
magnitude which I'll show in a minute
before I do I forgot I wanted to tell
you what blocking is in mean it's a it's
a word that meteorologists know about
but many many of us don't really and
this is from a paper we wrote in science
about this effect and Atmospheric
blocking and this this is a news and
views by Tim willings one of the real
experts on the jet stream
from Oxford England the normal jet
stream in the upper troposphere is along
this storm track and of course shifts up
and down the Atlantic according to some
decadal variability and shorter term
viability North Atlantic Oscillation and
like but when it is unhappy and develops
these huge meanders the way the Gulf
Stream does really and sometimes they
been back on themselves and form a
dipole vortex pair which just kind of
sits in place for three to five days or
even longer and and this this is trying
to swim upwind so to speak and it can
sit there and in this case bring cold
air down from the north right over the
UK and down to Spain in this cartoon so
blocking is a high amplitude meander of
the jet stream very energetic feature
and tends to happen when the jet stream
is in the south and in severe winters
which we've had many of recently in
Europe well they are blocked we may be
blocked here until spring this is
somewhere in southern Europe I can't
remember Oh Serbia he's looking at an
icicle in Serbia which you don't
normally see and so there's been some
very severe winters and and there's that
the impacts of blocking are very strong
in the winter of two thousand and five
and six this is the this is the episodes
of blocking from january january through
februari through march so you see each
one of these is a blocking period and
that can add up to a very severe winter
down stream of the block well serpa
Hawkin and working with me i was really
her idea was to take a new product from
n car which is a renown tree analysis of
the whole 20th century's weather in the
middle of the troposphere the 500 Hector
Pascal height and that was done by
taking surface data back through I think
1870 hard to believe early that you
could know what the jet stream was doing
in eighteen seventy or nineteen twenty
but the jet stream communicates to the
ground very effectively if you
experienced a cold air outbreak in
in Texas or Oklahoma you know what the
jet stream is doing and what we have now
from compo Adele a 10-car is a real
analysis and I'm really sorry that the
time scale is lost here this is this is
1900 and this is 2010 so this is a
hundred and ten years of blocking
occurrences in the European in the
Atlantic sector and you see there's
variability significant between ten and
twenty percent variations in the
occurrence of blocking in the wintertime
in the 1930s this is that 1930s here and
this is the recent period from 1990s to
the present so something as high
frequency as this violent weather kind
of breaking of a jet stream wave
actually come in clusters which do have
an inner annual or even century long
time scale so that's exciting and what
what we did was superimposed on top of
that curve the an index of the warmth of
the North Atlantic and that's the red
curve here it has the raw data is the
dashed mo curve which includes a global
warming kind of trend over you see this
is the time scale here 1900 through 2010
finally showing but the the so-called
amo index of the warmth of the entire
North Atlantic Ocean is has itself an
early 20th century warming in the 1930s
and then a dip in a some extra activity
around nineteen sixty 1980 but then a
persistent second major warming right up
until the present and there's some is
very low statistical reliability I admit
completely but there's some feeling that
these go together that warm ocean and
high-end frequent episodes of blocking
are somewhat correlated and we just saw
an example where the cause and effect
can be actually found in in in numerical
experiments by scafe well the warm
period of the earliest 20th century is
one of the great mysteries of climate
science it was really before the full
impact of greenhouse
gases was so strong as it is now and if
I've got I'm not sure I have this number
right i think it's 500,000 tons of cod
were caught in the labrador sea west of
Greenland and there no Cod there now and
they're generally are not Cod there they
spawn off of Iceland and are in the
ocean circulation to the Labrador sea
and they were happily they were happy as
clams you might say in the warmth of the
early 20th century starting in the late
1920s and extending really till nineteen
fifty five or so so there was a huge Cod
harvest their many indications of this
warming and not just rumor or uncertain
temper thermometers but lots of proof
that that was real and so here we are in
the recent heavily instrumented period
since 1990 or so this period of Earth's
of a satellite altimeters and Argo
floats and grace gravity satellites and
a wonderful global observing system for
the ocean which we now have and so we
have I'd say one of the challenges in
our science really big challenge is you
know if we're going to really
persuasively predict the 21st century's
climate we have to be able to understand
this major early 20th century warming
and what's happening right now and
there's some very good ideas I won't
have time today to talk to sort through
the thoughts about why this happened so
long ago and but you know the it was the
time of the Dust Bowl in Central us
strong and cold air outbreaks from the
north and drought for 10 years a lot of
crazy things were happening back in this
period and it's not at all clear what
the prime mover of that was but we're
now in this heavily instrumented period
so we can we can talk at least about
what the details of the current warming
are so I'm going to move into this area
of late 20th century early 21st century
oceanography I'm sorry again apologize
about the lost text up here but this is
a penny holiday from the UK
and and many other people have collected
temperature records and we've lost the
time scale but this is roughly 1980
through 2010 and these are temperature
records all the way from barents sea for
Gloria bear island is in the barents sea
entrance norwegian sea south to norway
southern norwegian sea faroe islands
shower Shetland channel rock all trough
is west of Ireland so this is going from
north to south and you see over time
this very strong warming and the
magnitude from a cold to the warm is of
order 3 degrees in many places or more
so that experiment of Adam escapes I
showed you was not out of the ballpark
of natural variability we're subjecting
the the ecosystems of the ocean and the
atmosphere to really unprecedented warps
until you go back to the 1930s the
salinity field is carrying along a
similar track saltier and warmer but he
twins and it's the water is less dense
than it was so oh my golly this has very
big what what's been going on in this
period is quite interesting since 1992
when they when the satellite altimetry
network was established we have we can
graph 20-some years twenty one or two
years of the history of the oprah ocean
circulation as seen by satellite
altimeters and what serpa and i did here
was to find the principal empirical
orthogonal function of the variability
of this northern atlantic region this is
the shape of that function but it's not
you don't have to even think about AOS
just think of it as mostly a trend from
1992 here to 2011 this this down slope
here is amounts to a slowing of the
subpolar gyre and a rising of the sea
surface because it's a it's a dish of
a low of pressure a low of sea surface
elevation here so it's been rising and
slowing and this has been falling and
slowing in parts of the Gulf Stream
North Atlantic current system it's it's
tricky because the Gulf Stream transport
does not seem to have changed over near
where Tom Ross fee has his his ship
based time series at the same same time
interval so it's down in the Florida
Straits that transported the Gulf Stream
does not seem to have very much
interannual or decadal variability but
up here where it's recirculating and
where it's deciding whether or not to go
north it does seem to have changed and
remarkably so over this many years so
this is coincident with that period of
warming and so we have to figure out
what is the connection between the two
an altimeter measures the sea surface
elevation and a sort of a Swiss Army
knife of ocean instruments because it
the height of the sea surface is partly
the ocean the heat content it you know
thermal expansion there are other things
they're like salinity and freshwater and
non heat related things affecting the
sea surface elevation but it's fairly
highly correlated and so this actually
is is coincident with the warming of the
region that we just showed it's not the
it's not actually a heat map but it's
suggestive and I'll show you the actual
heat map this is the global ocean heat
content difference integrated from the
surface down to 700 meters so it's the
upper quarter or fifth of the ocean but
it's the most active thermally the
difference from 1982 to 2010 so these
are warming regions if you averaged over
the entire globe that's the glutes
global warming right I mean more than
ninety percent as you'll read in the New
IPCC documents more than ninety percent
of the excess heat gained by the Earth's
system has gone into the ocean very much
less in the land surface in the
atmosphere and so if you integrate
averaged over this all you get a curve
which looks like this this is the
tenth of the world ocean estimated by
very careful and hard work starting with
Sid Leavitt us and many many brilliant
people working to get this curve right
between 1992 on the left and 2010 on the
right basically the rising of the rising
of the heat content of due to global
warming and you notice there's no hiatus
here we get an incredible flack from
people who don't believe in any human
impacts on global climate because they
say well you know what happened the last
12 15 years it stopped I mean so it's
not real humans don't do anything
because surface temperature of the
atmosphere is a quirky statistic and
there's so much geography which you set
you what you see here all this ups and
downs making that single number i think
the ocean is a really good thermometer
for the climate system and it doesn't
seem to have that hiatus which is kind
of interesting anyway this is a
beautiful figure it shows the depth of
penetration of this heat vs. latitude
the the very deep dominated by the
northern atlantic really this this
ailment thing here not showing quite so
clearly here is that is the western
pacific which is a big positive region
for sea surface height change and i said
they're correlated the heat content and
the elevation of the sea surface but
that correlation is a little bit lost
there and so that the Islanders in the
western Pacific have been experiencing
something like a meter of sea surface
elevation change in the in recent
decades I'm sorry this is a zonal
average over the whole world yeah just
integrate this way but this is the shape
and so we want to concentrate on that
shape again and here it is serp and I've
worked it out from another data set and
well actually an ODC data zero to seven
hundred meter heat content sorry we've
lost the surface the caption but this is
a change over that same period 19 wait a
minute let me get this right one does
that
lost the time scale here 1993 to nuke I
see this is early 1990s relative to 2007
to 2011 sorry about that so this is the
warming that we're talking about notice
how it wraps around the subpolar gyre is
a beautiful way suggesting that it's
moving in part in the boundary currents
that are cyclonic ly carrying it around
and it's got a big hole in the middle
here which is very surprising and
something we're trying to understand
right now but this is the clothes in
view and with the vectors are the mean
circulation according to grace and
eltima tree in that region so what
you've seen so far in the talk is the
early 20th century warming here and the
current global warming here in the 1990s
to 2000s and there the surface signature
of these is is is defines what's called
the amo and Atlantic multidecadal
oscillation amo I think it's much better
to call it Murda multidecadal that's
written wrong multidecadal variability
rather than oscillation because it's
really not a simple oscillator but this
is the story of 20th century climate
really in a nutshell and salinity we've
taught we started to talk with fresh
water and if you look at this figure
from Bob Dixon Adele a marine old
section of the change in salinity of the
Atlantic you see its salt here in the
upper density classes near the surface
and in the scent in the tropics and
fresher in the high latitudes where
we've been looking so the hydrologic
cycle Excel or the possible acceleration
of the the increase of the hydrologic
cycle would is imprint is just this more
evaporation here becoming saltier more
precipitation and runoff and possibly
Arctic outflow making it fresher in the
high latitudes so these are all
tremendously important indices you'll
see in the IPCC documented a newer
version of this figure by other authors
you can see how
is coming together as a dynamical and
thermo dynamical story a very exciting
one to get right and I'm going to finish
the talk fairly soon but I want to kind
of is I lead up to that I hope I've
convinced you that you need to know the
structure and the shapes and
distributions of these functions
otherwise you just don't have anything
about the circulation and probably don't
have very much about the climate so
we're looking at rather fine scale
detail that you get out of our modern
global observing network out of robotic
see gliders and Argo floats and
high-resolution numerical models and we
somehow I have to learn to input those
into into improving the coarse
resolution climate models so these are
the warm path to the Arctic that I've
been talking about here's the Gulf
Stream again turning left partly
recirculating it breaks into three
branches here a tight recirculation of
the subtropical gyre going around and a
branch going as part of the warm
meridiana overturning up to the high
latitudes and the mixture of warm and
cold waters as it as it moves through
the system to determine two sides the
climate of the biologically active zones
of the northern seas and so this little
mixing valve here is all important and
it's obviously a detail you know it's
something you you wouldn't be able to
get right without some resolution and so
how do we do that well here's some
resolution this is a close-in look at Al
symmetric surface currents in that same
region here we are gulfstream turning
left going north and here it is here in
a snapshot Gulf Stream turning left
going are but this is a snapshot of 1 10
day period in 2005 and I'm we may or may
not be able to animate this this is the
animation little time scale is going by
up here and the Gulf Stream is of course
wonderfully active it's throwing off
meanders and eddies there's a something
called the man at
here which is a little hard to see but
it's an anticyclone that if you average
this picture this an anticyclone sitting
sitting right here east of the grand
banks of Newfoundland and here it is
becoming a Northland current and
carrying warm water mixing in some
unknown way with the subpolar gyre up
here east of st. John's Newfoundland and
then turn carrying on so it's obviously
a complicated story to average over but
you know you've got a model you can this
is data this is observations but you can
now begin to approach this with
high-resolution numerical modeling this
is the time average of that picture the
man Eddie this huge anticyclone sitting
there confusing us terribly at right at
the and then the North Atlantic Current
which turns East here and the sort of
mixing valve I suggested is operating
all along here it was cold fresh
Labrador Current water just just in
shore of the warm say line subtropical
water moving northwards so the mixing of
those two is obviously very important
and the a wonderful paper I mean our
theory of this thing is that that long
period of slowing of the subpolar gyre
has allowed the subtropical influence to
really dominate so that if we if we have
slowed this circulation which we
demonstrably have we have this satellite
image symmetry is really very clear
about that then that suggests that this
branch can become more influential in in
working on the eastern subpolar gyre so
that's as far as serpa and i got but
then Along Came is a very interesting
model study of of destriers mercier and
tre of France and what they did was take
one quarter degree numerical model and
played the same game they they exposed
it to observed atmospheric forcing and
they looked at what was flowing into the
North northern seas and they they
divided it into these stream lines
coming from this
warm subtropics and these chip
streamlines recirculating from the cold
northern gyre so that some of these two
is what crosses this line here and what
they were found was that as the subpolar
gyre weakens the flow south of 50 North
everything in this period is actually
decreasing the overturning circulation
is actually weakening in their
calculation and probably in reality and
even so the flow south of that this flow
hear this roar motor is decreasing less
in transport than the northern
recirculation and so there's less
competition for the warrant southern
branch of the North Atlantic Current
unless dilution of its warmth and so
that's a entirely independent model
study suggesting I think the same result
for the story of of this warm rim of the
Labrador sea and this major climate
event of the twenty 20th and early 21st
century I'm coming close to the end here
I wanted to show that we know okay what
do we do about this complexity that you
seem to need to predict major climate
changes in the northern Atlantic and in
the atmosphere above what you have to do
to start with is to map the diagonal
mixing that is to say the transformation
of warm waters into cold and salty
waters into fresh or vice versa that
obviously mixes water masses in the
North Atlantic Current so what we've
just seen is visible in this data here
it's actually model data from the high
calm numerical model it's a very small
print up here describing what that's
about my collaborators at florida state
university job yahoo and eric shaw CA
and Bill Schmitz what we've done is
launched tracers in the Florida current
and follow them through this complex
very rich unstable circulation and that
single point source down here to the
left after five years has spread itself
through the subtropical gyre the
recirculation gyre and fanned out across
the northern
Atlantic and after 10 years even more so
so you might look at this and say well
why did you need all that detail all
those Eddie's why don't you just put in
a big diffusivity and well that's the
object really is to learn how to do that
and get it right but the net effect of
the Eddie missus scale Eddie turbulence
of the ocean is to make it very
diffusive and you can see that in this
distribution of warps as it reaches to
the far north so that's the kind of
thing we're trying to do now to do this
quantitatively is some work and the
Meridian overturning circulation of the
oceans is almost always defined and
described in terms of the the zonal
average of the vertical and Myrtle
velocity so this slightly off screen
picture is the overturning of one of
those climate models it shows northward
flow of warm water and sinking in the
high-latitude 65 north then flow back as
cold overflows and cold Labrador sea
water and the other of those two models
has a rather different but similar
appearing overturning circulation now
this is usually all you see from
numerical models and climate models but
the trouble is you just can't diagnose
anything from these figures you have to
go back and to the geography that we've
described and have some kind of a model
dialogue to look at where this
transformation of warm waters too cold
occurs and match it to the air sea flux
of heat and freshwater so that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to make
a theta s meridian or overturning
circulation theta being potential
temperature s being salinity and it
works I'd say impressively well and it
tells you where the mixing sites in the
ocean model are and then you we have a
whole Legion of observers of mixing
turbulent mixing in the ocean who are
beginning to fill in criss cross maps of
where violent mixing actually does occur
and I'll talk actually some about that
tomorrow and in talking about see
gliders but this is the upper layers of
the ocean
this is this red blob here is a
expression of the wintertime convection
transforming waters in the edge of the
subpolar gyre producing what's called
subpolar mode water and some
transformation occurring in the boundary
current as you go down to deeper levels
you begin to encounter this is deeper
densities I mean higher densities deeper
below the surface you encounter lebra
Darcy convection which is cooling the
water here transforming it mixing in the
boundary currents these red and blue
stripes here and mixing in the region we
just looked at this intense western
boundary current Gulf Stream region so
this is where that oh sorry and further
one more layer down we we encounter the
opposite tendency of the if you can if
you converge water into one density
class you diverge it from another and
that's describes mixing and this is what
the change in colors here represents so
we we basically are in this hicom model
able to localize where water mass
transformation occurs and turn that into
a Myrtle overturning described in the
phase space of Oceanography which is the
temperature and salinity coordinates it
includes the heat flux and the fresh
water flux free for nothing once you've
done that so that's that I'm describing
the beginning of a story and I'll have
to stop just about now but the I hope I
hope you can appreciate how much you
need to do that in comparison with this
rather stripped-down overturning
circulation figures that we always see
from zonal averaging because we just
can't diagnose truth and the truth value
of those by themselves so we want to
reproduce the key climate all
climatological mean circulation
transports the heat and geo chemicals
sites of transformation of water masses
and this involves upscaling from high
resolution models and observations to
coupled climate models CCMS and also
diagnose the dominant variability events
of the past 150 years and much
further and particularly the early 20th
century warming and the present Atlantic
warming which is the two major events of
the last 150 years so that's the goal
it's not finished but we do have now a
global observing system for the ocean
the tower a and the equator of moorings
the Argo floats 3700 I think now
satellites scanning the earth for
currents temperatures heat content
weather and the Internet those are our
that's our modern observing system and
I'll leave you with this image of the
jet stream over the Atlantic and these
are blocking events severe meanders of
the jet stream which caused arctic air
in in their wake to come down and freeze
the Europeans thank you